Aaron Carter speaks out after his arrest
et has learned the 29 year old singer
was arrested in Haber sham County
Georgia on Saturday night a spokesperson
for the Haversham County Sheriff's
Office tells ET Aaron was arrested on
charges of DUI refusal possession of
less than one ounce of marijuana and
drug related objects a representative
for Aaron released a statement
exclusively to ET telling us it all
started when a tire on Aaron's car had
an issue so he stopped at an Auto Zone
in Cornelia Georgia the rep said quote
after being at the store and requesting
help to get his alignment fixed he was
arrested inside by several police
officers with aggression the police also
revoked his rights to have an attorney
the statement goes on to say Aaron was
not in a moving vehicle when he was
arrested and charged with a DUI adding
that Aaron feels quote his celebrity was
targeted as for the tweets from Aaron's
older brother Nick offering to get him
help Aaron says in part quote why
wouldn't he call me directly and have a
conversation instead of making this
about him through a very public forum
that's not cool at all to use me for his
PR and kick me while I am down